زياره ابنك انت تزامنوا مع توسيع الخطط
الاستيطانيه الاسرائيليه منذ نحو سته اشهر
اذا اخذت وتيره اسرع بعد مجيء حكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو الجديده ففي الرابع من
اغسطس الماضي صدقت لجنه التخطيط والبناء
التابعه للسلطات الاحتلال على مخطط لبناء
1461 جديده في القدس المحتله وبعد شهر
صدقت لجنه التخطيط المركزيه على اقامه حي
السلطانين جديد جنوب القدس المحتله يشمل
761طانيه وبعد ثلاثه ايام ارجعت اسرائيل
البحث في تنفيذ مخطط بريطا مثير للجدل في
منطقه اي واحد تعارضه الاداره الامريكيه
بشده والذي يشمل بناء اكثر من ثلاثه الاف
واربع مئه وحده استطانيه لانه سيقضي على
حل الدولتين اذ ان المخطط يعزل القدس
تماما عن اي امتداد فلسطيني ويقطع جنوب
الضفه الغربيه عن وسطها
في العشرين من الشهر الجاري قام مستوطنون
بالاستيلاء على ارض قرب مستوطنه مجدلين
المقامه على اراضي بلده قصر جنوب مدينه
نابلس في الضفه الغربيه المحتله وبعد
ثلاثه ايام اعلنت مديريه التخطيط والبناء
في القدس انها بدات التخطيط لبناء مترو
الانفاق في المدينه بهدف ربطها مدن وبلدات
اسرائيليه عده بالاضافه الى مستوطنه جميل
الواقعه الى الشرق